you know when welcome to this video
didn't I see see I'm playing yes I
thought it is a Sicilian you have
blatant I think he played the special
coffee earlier game so this is what's
right memory 500 k think usually you go
like this
don't quite remember this stuff but okay
this kind of this kind of situation is
of course not bad for black but why does
also i think quite quite okay so Knight
to f5 is sent already an option in this
position I think I had this against him
like almost exactly the same kind of
position okay I cannot sell and increase
my central control a little bit black
definitely and cannot do all that much
so yeah night f5 you probably moves the
night f form is an idea doesn't feel he
doesn't feel hot that it is any
dangerous oh
I mean isn't it somewhat dangerous may
be created before I know I mean you just
place like every move immediately it's
that bad I mean I would think that this
is somewhat dangerous for black it
doesn't agree it seems absolutely not so
let's see I don't get to the light
squares or that easily he controls most
of this so okay I'm taking it first you
probably will take with the other porno
he takes with this pond without any any
contemplation okay I simply don't
understand the position I feel if
everything is so obvious him
so how to do this I need to get to g6
possible yeah maybe just here and cleans
you form the funny thing they said that
knight on d4 looks good but it doesn't
do anything especially not in terms of
Defense non-threatening Queen g6 and
this would actually win immediately I
really felt you should take with the
deep water okay if he takes now on f1
Andrew kf8 I play Bishop age 7 and windy
exchange and probably with it the game
but Queen g6 is extremely extremely a
strong threat note that the night has no
squares and it looks nice but it doesn't
do anything check ya mook f8 is giving
up the exchange I just wanted to ever
have something better here i can if i
take it what what about this if i take
it and play Queen to d7 how is he
defending against this like Bishop g64
made I don't think he is 92 is a counter
mating idea though okay check let's grab
it I'm also threatening um rupees every
book f7 here some he doesn't have a free
like a free movie available so um Queen
e7 may be coming up
okay let's play them let's keep it
simple you cannot avoid the cooling
trade we can give me the Queen and
probably wasn't Muslim black resign so
it is it is a ruling anyway mmm yeah
sometimes really amazed that they like
play instant moves in very critical
situations that I really feel like you
should think I mean I don't know maybe
I'm just not seeing it right so like f4
okay what what does the engine give it
gives us roughly equal which I kind of
understand that it shouldn't be all that
terrible for him f6 and now i put the
night here yeah 24 for example was an
interesting move to consider here or
maybe Quincy five as well the teachers
took it immediately and this fields
already very dangerous to me because the
night is not doing much but I have an
attack I just have an attack and he has
to go age six there's no other movement
since this is getting killed immediately
so age six and now we see the data the
light squares are weak and now I feel
details was clearly the only move you
cannot open up the F file for me also I
mean this is going to be dangerous but i
was thinking queen to be one of my idea
but the engine suggestion of rooks e1 is
strong it threatens c5 and then
creatively one so I got the idea Ryder
probably I probably would have played
this one that's very likely intending to
sneak into g6 and this is already
dangerous but i think this D'Souza's
just right yeah plus 5 mm and this was
played in two seconds and this is simply
i mean i know people i know it but their
meat stating that all the time but this
is an extremely critical situation and
then
which is the Blitz game and so on but if
you want to take something away from
those games just this is an extremely
critical moment and the difference is
between losing and like having problems
but still having a game to play and then
here you're just toast that's just over
I get onto the light squares and and its
end of game Queen h5 was maybe stronger
but is it a different jacket like this
and he goes through give aid and this is
this check was made already okay yeah
this is a Franco here it's a force made
him check this is wins check also quite
quite easily our Queenie for I didn't
see that but ok this is a technical
winner he cannot really avoid the green
trade you can try this but I'm training
wins anyway and the endgame is an easy
win so take some time for critical
decisions even in a blitz game I mean
yet like four and a half minutes left
why not take 10 seconds and then figure
out okay this one loses avoided them ok
guys thanks for watching